c'est rsa vous allez faire le sketch de
l'apéro sauf le début le début parce que
oui le début mais il va aussi vous
rapprochez vous avez tous canton je ne
savais pas bien mais quand on fait un
apéro ici on le fait vraiment je vous le
dis donc je vous amener des cacahuètes
des chips des oeufs et des tuques a
aussi on a des hauts et
des bas donc je voudrais vous en a mené
au cours de votre chèque est vraiment
parler vous l'un en face de l'autre
c'est important pour un sketch que vous
entendiez bien et vous devez manger tout
le temps ça veut dire tout le temps
puisque c'est le cas des apéros fait
tout ce qu'elle dit l'apéro mais vous
vous avez tout le temps manger la corde
et non non non pas le plus heureux quoi
manger c'est et scénariste
attention donc c'est parti je viens vite
et
peut-être vous voir pendant le sketch et
vous parlez n'hésitez pas à rajouter ni
paix dans votre quête jean
alesi sebhaoui dp oui bien sûr comme ça
merci à l'ailé je voulais c'est que les
chiffres mais les tuques également allée
j c'est parti on est en forme ferland
bon resto mais je te sais comment gérer
vas-y c'est forte et a fait partie c'est
parti
l'arrêt comme cette année gadio pour soi
dit
vraiment comme
c'est bon train entre
les gares de ath en 17 rencontres qu'on
va pas chez ruquier
ah non ban est
désormais le skate le voulu jeter pape
continue alors quoi de ta foi
de tout est beau comme c'est par la main
alors t'as pas d'escale la femme mais
chaque année tu sais j'ai fait un cadeau
l'an dernier
[Rires]
j'ai fait
le voyage toujours
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors quoi ta femme
j'ai offert le voyage organisé au
sénégal de soins
y avait pas un conte de serveurs
non
[Musique]
wackenbach d'animaux
clonés ne m'aurait plu j'ai offert
l'abonnement femme actuelle enfin
l'actuel actuellement c'est bien ce
journal awene
fond de doper le font pas trop
d'ailleurs
le terme et
non la vraie course âprement pour le
spectacle
il porte le
nom de vince un drame d'abord
salut
[Applaudissements]